on est conscient là que il y a des
citoyens qui vont être très très déçus
le briefing de 6 m'a conformé ce que je
soupçonnais depuis longtemps c'est un
geste qui va droit au cœur
à la lumière de ce qu'on a vécu après 8
ans de Justin Trudeau tout semble être
brisé on est pleinement conscient du
défi qu'il faut reconnecter avec
l'ensemble des Québécois la SAC nous a
dit nous sommes prêts à qu'on les a
laissé aller tu n'acceptable et honteux
que des générations du jeûne ont été
exposées à ce type d'abus là
[Musique]
ils sont surveillés admirés critiquer
détester aussi parfois une chose est
sûre nos politiciennes et nos
politiciens laissent rarement
indifférents et quel endroit au
félicitations cette année lesquels les
canalise les déceptions leur est au
bilan ça c'est la section ou d'habitude
on commence par les bons côtés on met
les mauvais commentaires dans le milieu
qu'on finit sur une bonne note alors le
politicien qui a plus brillé on se
disait
Ottawa Québec ou les deux Chantal et
j'en ai pris deux au Québec la ministre
l'immigration Christine prechette parce
que ça fait du bien
et qui parle des vraies affaires et on
verra à terme où ça va mener mais c'est
un dossier extraordinairement important
pour le Québec et qui avait vraiment
besoin de quelqu'un qui voulait en faire
quelque chose et je crois que c'est le
cas et ça donne une conversation sur des
bases beaucoup plus factuelles que celle
qui avait animé monsieur Legault depuis
quelques années et au niveau fédéral
écouter j'ai choisi le chef conservateur
sortant
qui donne des leçons de c'est quoi être
un chef qui veut être Premier ministre à
son successeur depuis déjà plusieurs
semaines monsieur autour qui quitte la
politique à la fin de la session donc il
y aura une élection complémentaire en
Ontario dans sa circonscription mais qui
est celui qui a certainement présenter
le meilleur argumentaire sur le dossier
de l'ingérence chinoise et pas parce
qu'il était un voisin de chalet ou que
début Johnson faisait partie de la
Fondation Trudeau mais parce qu'il était
le chef du parti qui a été ciblé aux
dernières élections et qui pouvait
parler d'expérience sur la foi en plus
de ce que lui avait dit les services de
sécurité donc il est possible de
s'informer des faits auprès du SARS et
d'en parler après de façon intelligente
aux communes un exercice auquel se
refuse totalement Pierre Poivre qui dit
adore ça voudrait dire que j'aurais
plutôt d'orienter en tout cas j'attends
encore que le RC RS mettre monsieur ou
tout dans une petite cellule
pas parce qu'il doit faire un discours
grâce au privilège parlementaire entre
autres qui articulée de façon totalement
raisonnable les raisons pour lesquelles
ceux qui veulent une enquête publique
peuvent avoir raison d'en vouloir que
c'était c'était vraiment c'était une
excellent discours de quelqu'un qui
pourrait être Premier ministre et puis
là et puis là c'est plus lui qui est à
la tête
on va te la montrer la porte si s'ils
avaient pu montrer la porte Steven un
peu en 2004 quand tu es perdu les
élections est-ce qu'ils auraient été au
pouvoir en 2006
j'ai choisi à Ottawa la ministre
fédérale des sports Pascal symptômes qui
est quand même une nouvelle élu c'est
pour quelqu'un qui a un moment
d'expérience
plus généralement quand on arrive au
cabinet par la porte des sports on
entend peu parler de cette élu là et là
elle est sur les sur les feux de la
rampe depuis des mois avec toutes les
inconduites sexuelles mais psychologique
qui a eu dans les le sport d'élite au
pays il y a eu Hockey Canada bien sûr
très médiatisé les ligues de hockey
junior majeur un peu partout mais aussi
la box de la natation à peu près tous
les sports ont passé le bobsleigh il y a
des problèmes de harcèlement dans le
sport d'élite et elle a décidé de s'en
occuper avec les faibles leviers qui est
là parce que c'est fédérations
sportives-là ne relèvent pas du
gouvernement elle a un peu de
financement dans certains cas mais elle
a quand même transformé la manière dont
les conseils d'administration vont être
nommés plus indépendants plus rigoureux
moins rempli d'intérêt elle a retiré le
financement lorsque c'était le temps je
trouve qu'elle travaille bien pour un
dossier qui est quand même assez
imposant et qu'elle n'attendait
certainement pas de voir gérer comme
quoi être président de notre syndicat
c'est une bonne façon
alors parce que c'est très bonne et à
Québec dans une session ou beaucoup de
ministres ont eu de la difficulté le
Bernard de rimville
ericaire et autres je trouve que
Geneviève Guilbault s'en est assez bien
sorti d'abord elle a ramassé tout ce qui
allait pas bien la Société d'assurance
automobile du Québec et du aussi qu'il y
en avait des choses qu'elle est pas bien
ça veut pas dire que c'est réglé
d'ailleurs c'était encore difficile mais
au moins il y a quelqu'un qui s'en est
occupé et on a dégommé le PDG au bon
moment pour donner une leçon que oui
elle a avoir de l'imputabilité lorsqu'il
y avait des cafouillages informatiques
comme ça et sur le troisième lien elle
faisait un peu pitié seul en conférence
de presse avec du liquide pourquoi on
change de position là toute seule alors
que le premier ministre lui était pas
quoi à ses côtés il aurait dû être là
puis assumer la volte-face il ne l'a pas
fait était tout seul elle plutôt
l'équipe toutes les critiques des
députés et des mères et des préfets de
la réussite de Québec mais en même temps
fallait que quelqu'un l'apprenne la
décision parce que dans l'état actuel
des choses c'était la bonne décision à
prendre puis elle a eu au moins le
courage de l'apprendre alors que c'est
pas facile donc je trouve que je viens
de Lebeau s'en est bien serré cette
session effectivement Michel je le fais
par rapport à mes attentes et dans le
code d'Ottawa mes attentes étaient très
faibles je parle du couple Trudeau signe
pensez jamais que ça allait marcher
peu de fois
mais reste que bon il y a des bavures il
y a des moments comme la Grèce sur
l'ingérence étrangère où ils sont pas
d'accord il reste que ça fonctionne et
que ça fait fonctionner le Parlement et
c'est ça qui est important dans une
situation gouvernement minoritaire ou le
Parlement est facilement pu bloqué et je
suis agréablement surpris de voir que ça
fonctionne à Québec c'est vraiment
l'inverse je veux dire les gens qui
m'ont plus impressionné depuis le début
de la session donc depuis l'élection
trois chefs de position même monsieur
Tanguay qui qui est un chef vétérinaire
et qui en même temps est candidat ou pas
candidats c'est compliqué c'est sentir
plutôt bien il faut dire que le
gouvernement des aide c'est comme ça que
ça se passe dans un parlement maillon
faible avec je vais commencer avec vous
qui est votre maillon en fait
ce premier ministre canadienne et
ministre des Finances que juste
ton ministre sont soumise
je l'ai déjà mis dans la catégorie des
ministres qui brille le plus mais là je
trouve que depuis plusieurs mois ce
n'est pas le cas sans dire qu'elle tire
son gouvernement vers le bas elle a un
effet neutre sur son gouvernement et ça
devrait être l'inverse parce qu'on est
en période d'incertitude économique
période de forte inflation et on n'a pas
l'impression que le travail de ministre
des Finances l'intéresse on l'entend peu
ou quand il communique elle communique
visiblement pas de la bonne manière
les déclarations sur le fait que si les
gens abandonnaient leur abonnement
dessiner plus de s'en sortir c'était
peut-être pas la déclaration du mais
c'est un budget qu'elle a déposé en plus
qui est assez sans saveur qui était pas
particulièrement inspiré ou inspirant et
donc on a l'impression qu'elle soit la
tête ailleurs peut-être qu'elle a la
tête à l'international il le goût de
retourner sur la scène internationale je
ne sais pas plein de rumeurs l'envoient
à le temps entre autres mais je peux pas
dire que quand je regarde j'étais un
Trudeau il y a avec lui un ou une
ministre des Finances fortes comme ça a
été le cas dans le fait des précédents
gouvernement et je pense que ça lui nuit
il n'a pas avec lui de crédibilité
économiques Christophe Willem ne joue
pas ce rôle là je trouve donc quel est
le maillon faible du gouvernement
Trudeau Michel
pierre polieve qui est le maillot faible
du Parlement actuellement on a besoin
d'un chef de l'opposition qui harcèle le
gouvernement sur les bons dossiers qui
et qui fait avancer le débat là on a
l'impression d'avoir
appelé ce soin de tireur de roche soit
imposable mais je vais faire un
filetbuster contre le budget c'est tout
ce qui est exagéré était dit devient
insignifiant c'était une super idée qui
répète ça souvent
je trouve que Monsieur foyer ferait
beaucoup trop souvent dans l'exagération
et que ça n'aide ça ne l'aide ni lui et
ça n'aide pas le Parlement non plus et
il a les deux rôles il y a le rôle de
s'opposer mais aussi le rôle de faire
marcher le Parlement j'entends j'ai
choisi la garde rapprochée Justin
Trudeau qui semble gérer parce que c'est
très centré de ça le pouvoir Ottawa en
se le cachera pas avant de blâmer un
ministre ou un autre y compris la
ministre des Finances d'ailleurs il faut
regarder
quand le gouvernement est brouillon et
désordonné et il a été il continue à
l'être il faut regarder la garde
rapprochée juste un Trudeau et dans le
moment l'impression qu'on a c'est
qu'ayant fait cette entente avec
Monsieur sing on se dit bon de toute
façon on aura toujours le temps de
préparer les essentiels
[Musique]
chinoise c'est un peu ça qui s'est passé
c'est les gens sans préoccupent ça va
passer c'est comme le reste il y a un
moment donné après X années au pouvoir
on commence à pu se rendre compte de de
la déconnexion qui s'accumule entre la
garde rapprochée d'un Premier ministre
et sa gestion des crises et l'électorat
et la réalité sur le terrain puis on est
un peu là-dedans et je crois que
Monsieur Trudeau qui a une zone de
confort avec son personnel donc qui
changerament son personnel aurait eu
avantage et pas mal trop tard à
une injection de 109
durée 8 ans auprès d'un Premier ministre
depuis tellement longtemps quelque chose
de pas normal dans durer l'entièreté non
c'est pas arrivé Bryan ma journée a
changé deux trois fois
[Musique]
c'est des jobs qui usent et à un moment
donné on finit par pu voir ou pu
entendre parce que on en a tellement vu
et tellement entendu quand on est plus
là-dedans et comme c'est elle qui
surveille le bureau du premier ministre
qui sont son chien de garde ça empêche
aussi beaucoup de choses de se rendre
jusqu'à monsieur c'est pas la première
fois qu'on l'entend cette critique là
mais
ils sont pas percolaires monsieur
Trudeau un prix citron Michel je
commence avec vous
j'avais beaucoup de choix
je vais le donner à Bernard drinville
un peu de crocodile sur le troisième
lien mais aussi pour être un ministre de
l'éducation qui
s'en prend et toujours en guerre avec
quelqu'un quand c'est pas un syndicat
d'enseignant c'est une direction d'école
toute cette réforme qu'il est en train
de faire de l'immigration de l'éducation
plutôt fait toujours le même pattern que
dans la carte c'est à dire on enlève les
contre-pouvoirs on ramène tout au
ministre je suis pas sûr que c'est la
meilleure façon de fonctionner et
de façon générale c'est pas quelqu'un
qui semble vouloir s'entendre avec son
milieu c'est quelqu'un qui me semble
vouloir le diriger de haut je pose une
très bonne idée j'entends
les qualificatifs on se rend compte ça
m'avait jamais frappé
j'ai choisi les parties libéra de
l'Ontario et du Québec les deux qui ont
lavent tourner en rond dans les deux cas
qui se retrouvent un peu dans les limbes
et qui ont pas l'air de savoir trop à
quoi ils sont censés servir en Ontario
le NPD est en train de les manger tout
rond comme dans d'autres provinces
d'ailleurs puis au Québec
j'engage je regardais leur première
vraie rencontre après la défaite
électorale puis je me disais mon vieux
c'est pas là qu'on a brassé de l'idée au
contraire il faut pas faire de vagues
donc on brosse pas d'idées et je trouve
que c'est un peu pathétique pour des
parties qui ont eu un historique une
histoire et des contributions
importantes à la société québécoise où
ontarienne
il serait pas là on s'en aperçoit pas
qui va se présenter
libéra
ux
bonne comparaison effectivement
pour des saisons des raisons assez
évidentes
parce qu'on à cause du troisième ligne
c'est de déclaration passée sur le fait
qu'il mettait son siège en jeu sur cette
pilote ces paroles là ça devient
difficile mais aussi sur le fait que
dans tout le fiasco informatique à la
salle alors que tu es le ministre de la
transition numérique tu ne sais pas de
ma faute je m'en occupais pas c'est
quelqu'un d'autre Geneviève Guilbaud
aussi s'en occupait pas il y avait quand
même commencé par dire on a une
responsabilité là-dedans on va corriger
la situation lui a commencé par dire
s'il vous plaît regardez ailleurs c'est
pas de ma faute ça faisait pas
particulièrement bonne impression
mettons-le je sais pas s'il va se
remettre de cette session là aussi au
prochain remaniement et chanceux qu'en
fait François Hugo n'aime pas les
remaniements il bouge peu son équipe
parce qu'il est un bon candidat à
quitter son poste de conseil des
ministres bon fini sur une bonne note
révélation de l'année il reste pas
beaucoup de temps mais je chantage je
vous entendre votre révélation parce
qu'il faut parler de l'atterrissage de
Paul Saint-Pierre tout le monde à
l'Assemblée nation c'est vraiment
pas autant pour son insuccès électoral
qui est réel là le PQ grand défaite mais
pas une façon différente d'articuler le
discours politique et dans Paris qui je
crois et rafraîchissante et fait avancer
les débats peut-être pas de la
souveraineté autant qu'il se
ou qu'ils veulent le croire mais
certainement qui joue un rôle utile et
c'est intéressant parce que pendant
longtemps on se disait le chef du Bloc
avec le succès du bloc qui a beaucoup
plus de sièges c'est comme la
personnalité souverainiste la plus
importante et au Conseil national du
blog qui on a invité pour faire
rejaillir un petit peu de l'éclat c'est
pas le saint-pierre
effectivement il y aurait pas été invité
il y a un arbre alors pas de coupe pas
comme tête d'affiche comme ça
probablement les cupcakes
j'ai choisi Catherine Fournier la
mairesse de Longueuil pour pour dignité
qu'elle a incarné tout au long de du
procès des choses qui se sont passés de
façon à faire ça mais aussi comme
représentante de toute la génération de
nouveaux maires qu'on a au Québec qui
l'on le voit pendant les feux de forêt
mais qu'on a vu dans toutes sortes de
dossiers est très présent sur les
questions d'environnement ce question de
changement climatique de qualité de vie
il y a il y a quelque chose qui se passe
là actuellement au Québec qui est
intéressant et ça se passe beaucoup plus
souvent dans les mairies que dans les
assemblées nationales
j'ajouterai juste que c'était la
première fois depuis très longtemps
qu'on sentait que quelqu'un avait le
goût de parler d'immigrations pour les
solutions que ça peut apporter au Québec
et non pas seulement pour les menaces
aux Français aux valeurs à la paix
sociale les travaux les étrangers
travaillent pas assez où ont pas un
assez gros salaire là on avait des
solutions à apporter une réforme de
programme cohérente il faut l'appliquer
ce sera pas simple mais là on sentait
qu'on a pour une fois le ministre qui a
envie que ça marche ça c'est déjà bien
effectivement c'est vrai que si on est
bien sorti madame fachette jusqu'ici
pour ignorer effectivement alors ça
c'était évidemment un regard sur les 6
premiers mois les événements les acteurs
là après la pause on va se tourner vers
la prochaine session il va se passer des
choses Québec Ottawa au-dessus de la
frontière aussi qu'est-ce qu'on devrait
surveiller plus attentivement quelques
pistes de solutions après la pause
[Musique]